as a new frontier opens in the space
market
[Applause]
some companies are trying to explore the
possibilities of harvesting resources
from the moon and other objects orbiting
the earth is a potential trillion dollar
payload of precious minerals and fuel
sources companies say that could be used
to power everyday electronic devices and
cars the moon is really created from the
same materials that earth is created
from it's about exploration to gather
those minerals and bring it back to
earth in an in an economically viable
way but as investment in space startups
reaches a record high some scientists
are skeptical that lunar mining could
become a reality questioning the high
cost of space travel and the potential
to destroy valuable geological sites
one company exploring the possibilities
of extracting the moon's resources is
astrobotic the startup is working with
nasa to develop lunar lander and rover
projects which astrobotic says could
help unlock the moon's potential in the
future but those efforts face mounting
challenges in the coming years here we
go
this is the business of space
a series focusing on the innovative
startups capitalizing on the commercial
space industry
pittsburgh was nicknamed the steel city
after its famed manufacturing industry
but now technicians at astrobotic wanted
to be reclaimed as a space hub
and that all starts with peregrine the
lander set to travel to the moon later
this year this is
the actual flight article and we're
actually still completing the propulsion
systems integration from the flight
article it's part of nasa's commercial
lunar payload program
that program is designed to
contract with companies like ours to
again deliver those payloads to the
surface of the moon on robotic vehicles
it could become the first american
spacecraft to land on the moon since the
last apollo mission more than 50 years
ago
[Music]
peregrine will deliver technologies to
be tested on the moon if successful they
may be used in nasa's artemis mission
that's the space agency's plan to return
humans to the moon with a view of
potential inhabitation and construction
on the lunar surface including the
building of a space camp where we're at
today is that we eventually want to
build the infrastructure and
capabilities to stay on the moon and
things like building habitats are
dependent on finding where the resources
are on the moon but some scientists say
that establishing permanent bases would
involve destroying large quantities of
the lunar soil which is called regolith
to make way for buildings and that
process could destroy clues as to how
the moon and by extension the earth
formed so just moving all this terrain
can eliminate that record of the impacts
on the lunar surface that we have but
also the upper part of the sula of the
lunar soil is like a record of what
happened in the previous millions years
from the from this and the sun
companies such as astrobotic and
government agencies like nasa are
interested in extracting from the
regolith to try and understand the
composition of its resources
their aim is to facilitate continued
exploration and economic development in
space scientists have previously
discovered a variety of minerals and
elements on the moon that could be used
to support that goal we can find their
oxygen in high quantities that it will
very helpful for for life support system
or from propellant and fuel we also can
find water ice in the lunar poles that
also it's very useful for for survival
of humans we can find other minerals and
other elements like silicon metals and
rare earth elements that we can use to
fabricate things that we need to use
there on the lunar surface but some
engineers are skeptical of the
possibilities of extracting usable
material in a space environment as many
technologies are still in development a
lunar mining operation would have to
make use of an unprecedented amount of
innovative tools with automated or
remote control machinery and pumps that
require minimal human oversight and
there are financial limitations to
harvesting those resources for use on
earth
the cost of fueling trips to and from
the lunar surface is not currently
economically viable some researchers say
payloads traveling in the peregrine
lander can be bought by private
companies investors or government
agencies such as nasa the u.s space
agency has commissioned astrobotic to
work on a series of rovers as payloads
small robots that will travel across the
surface of the moon and conduct
scientific experiments one of those
being developed here is the cube rover
cube rovers can be used for lots of
different missions and applications one
of the ones that we're really excited
about here is that we have rovers that
can drive several kilometers survive
lunar nights using small platforms that
are orders of magnitude cheaper than
prior rovers in the past allows us to
scan the surface of the moon in a much
more affordable and uh less complex way
so that we can understand where the
resources are located there's an
interesting phenomenon that happens with
smaller rovers that we're learning more
about
compared to larger rovers and that the
smaller rovers actually float on top of
the surface so your wheel designs for
these smaller rovers are likely going to
be very different than some of the
larger rovers but there are lots of
challenges associated with engineering
robotics to work on the lunar surface
the lunar surface have really extreme
temperatures and really high variation
of temperatures so that is a challenge
for the subsistence of the robbers and
the robotics elements but also the
terrain it has a huge amount of dust
that is really abrasive and corrosive
and it can damage the the subsystems
also radiation the radiation can play a
an impact on the especially in the
electronics of the system
as many startups race to capitalize on
the moon engineers and scientists say
there are limitations and consequences
one of them is the potential damage to
the environment there are drawbacks to
going to the moon permanently
some examples include leaving our assets
behind on the surface or disrupting
maybe the far side of the moon which is
totally undisturbed right now it's
looked at as one of the locations in our
solar system where you could look deep
into space and have no
interruptions no noise background noise
that can influence your observations but
given the environmental costs of mining
the earth some say that the moon's
resources could help reduce damage at
home companies such as astrobotic say
those potential benefits outweigh the
risk of disrupting the moon's natural
ecosystem i think that the ability to
harvest resources and use them to
protect our own planet is incredibly
helpful
other scientists are more skeptical that
the moon could in turn help protect the
earth but one point they can agree on is
that establishing bases on the moon for
human visitation could be decades away
and harvesting resources could take even
longer
for now looking for clues in the
regolith is the first step